when we
came up with that idea that
hyperphysicality
might be the thing that the students
might get their heads
around there hadn't been a global
pandemic
at that moment
how much that would mean was uh
well a bit like you're being ollie when
you said how should we live together
little did we know that that would be
even more important
the digital revolution i mean that's
20 30 years old um was
pushing us more and more
towards something that i suppose when i
started my studio i assumed
would be less and less role
for some of the things that i was
interested in and i
now feel silly for even thinking that it
would be less and less
that the that somehow
real places would matter less and it's
had the opposite effect
the digital revolution and this pandemic
has
just accelerated in a sense what was
happening already has pushed
the fact that um you couldn't get away
with lazy placemaking
you can't and now you really really
can't
as people are have
suddenly had the same lesson at the same
time across the entire planet
that you can stay at home you can kind
of work you can kind of learn you can
kind of eat you can kind of drink
you can kind of watch interesting things
and and
it isn't total catastrophe in fact
in some ways it's it's pretty good
and so suddenly there's uh there's
something down on the table
that uh that the physical world if
you're going to leave your home
if you're lucky enough to have a home
that's okay
it's uh it's the the physical world
outside the public life
beyond has got to really
be aware of how it connects with your
feelings and emotions
because it isn't an automatic thing that
you have to engage with to the extent
that you did in the past